this is where the most powerful man in
Britain is under close observation every
branch of government was already under
strain and now this Downing Street say
the Prime Minister who is 55 was moved
to the intensive care unit on the advice
of his medical team he's been given
oxygen but hasn't been put on a
ventilator
there is one nearby if needed senior
Cabinet Minister Michael Gove himself
isolating said Johnson is receiving
excellent support as we speak prime star
is in intensive care being looked after
by his medical team receiving the very
very best care from the teammates and
Thomas's and our hopes and prayers are
with him and with his family soon after
arriving at hospital Johnson tweeted I
went into hospital for some routine
tests as I'm still experiencing
coronavirus symptoms I'm in good spirits
and keeping in touch with my team as we
work together to fight this virus and
keep everyone safe but his symptoms
worsened on Monday evening there was
clearly much more cause for concern the
Foreign Secretary Dominic Robb will
stand in for Johnson where necessary
chairing the government's daily
coronavirus meeting in Downing Street
he's an experienced politician but
there's been little time to prepare the
government's business will continue and
the Prime Minister is in safe hands with
the brilliant team absent Thomas's
hospital and the focus of the government
will continue to be on making sure at
the Prime Minister's Direction all the
plans for making sure that we can defeat
coronavirus and pull the country through
this challenge will be taken forward
messages of support have been flooding
in for the prime minister across
Britain's political spectrum including
the newly elected leader of the Labour
Party we will support the government
where we can do that but we will
challenge them where it's necessary but
the purpose of the challenge is to make
sure that if there are mistakes they
could be put right or things need to
happen more quickly they can happen more
quickly president Emmanuel macron of
France has wished Johnson a speedy
recovery and the u.s. President Donald
Trump described Johnson as a good friend
I found Boris to be a fantastic person
just
like a fantastic warm strong smart guy
he loves his country you see that I mean
he fought like like hell for his country
and intensive care is big stuff this is
a challenging time for Johnson's family
his fiancee Kari Simmons is recovering
from the virus herself she is pregnant
with their first child they haven't been
able to see each other for several weeks
Johnson's personal battle with the virus
has shaken the government and the
country just as scientists say Britain
is entering one of the most deadly weeks
of the pandemic Nev Barker al-jazeera
wory challenge is a correspondent in
London this hour joining us from outside
the hospital where Boris Johnson is
being cared for so Rory do we know any
more about how mr. Johnson is doing okay
we had an update from the prime
minister's spokesperson about an hour
ago and it seems there hasn't been a
significant change since the early
morning and since he was admitted to
intensive care
last night we're being told that he is
stable that he's in good spirits that
he's been given oxygen but he hasn't
been put on a ventilator and that there
has been as yet no diagnosis of
pneumonia but the fact is that Boris
Johnson is pretty much out of action for
the time being and as we heard there in
needs report Dominic rob is deputizing
where necessary now the United Kingdon
does not have the same kind of
constitutionally ordains chain of
command to say the United States for its
president vice president etc it's a bit
more vague here but yeah Dominic Robbins
deputizing for now if he is
incapacitated then Russia sunic the
Chancellor of the Exchequer steps in and
I suppose with Dominic Raab we can look
at it as you know the Prime Minister is
still the prime minister he has set the
course
Dominic Robb has been given the tiller
for a while to keep the ship on track
basically
he can't hire and fire ministers and any
matters of national security are being
decided by the cabinet's principle of
collective responsibility Rory
talk to us about this new report this
modelling that's come out from the
University of Washington regarding the
art break in the UK is that cause for
concern well I think it certainly is
because these figures from at the
University of Washington the Institute
for Health metrics and evaluation that
the School of Medicine there are very
alarming they are suggesting that the
United Kingdom could have 66,000 deaths
at the end of the first wave of this
pandemic now that's far in excess of the
numbers that the UK was using with its
modelling when it brought in the social
distancing measures it was anticipating
that with social distancing it could
limit deaths to about 20,000 well 66,000
deaths if that transpires would put the
United Kingdom as definitely the worst
hit country in Europe this same
institution is suggesting that Italy
that what would be the second bit a
second worst hit might have 20,000
deaths it points to the facts that the
UK was comparatively late in bringing in
social distancing measures and the what
it says is that the lack of capacity in
intensive care units like the one that
Boris Johnson is currently in but I
think perhaps responding to to this
worrying report the spokesperson for the
PM said hold on a second we do have
capacity in intensive care units there's
plenty of capacity around the country
and we do have enough oxygen thank you
for that update there Rory challon's
live from London